As far as icon are concerned, state chart compromise between the rectangles that
we saw in the ovals to a thing called round-tangles, rounded cornered
rectangles. They can, they can have labels indicating state name.
They can have arcs connecting them which is a,
a directed arc that is there's going to be an arrowhead at one end.
And the arch's themselves can be labeled with the event causing the transition,
possibly with a slash and the action taken when the the event occurs.
Also, there's a way to indicate what the default or initial state is.
In the case of state charts this is having a small circle that's filled in.
You know blackened. And the final state in this case, the final state is one in
which there is a concentric outer ring around a filled in a filled in circle.